[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right
are going to be some hard hitting
questions here tonight oh it's going to
be so hard
so hard
uh hello everybody and welcome to black
man beyond my name is mark bernardin
[Music]
and uh today i am i'm honored by and
just thrilled to get the chance to
talk to a guy i've never met before
except for last night yeah
we don't talk about that though we don't
talk about that no no i don't think we
should talk about that okay but
we will talk was that too loud do if i
get too close does it get weird
how is it sounding
does it sound good good yeah
ah yes oh jeff goldblum ah yes yes love
the uh the shirt very andy warhol ask
yes yes
it's my birthday it's my birthday
no it's not really okay that's just when
i think of joe jeff goldblum and thor
ragnarok i think of his pleasure barge
oh right right right right and the the
the
yeah you know you know the button he
presses to make everything fun
um so we got really dirty really fast
yeah well you did i did i mean you're
totally playing pg over here yes of
course and prince george
letters
um
i love the podcast that begins
frightfully off the rails from the gym
um but no we we first sort of came into
the same sphere i think about two years
ago in the height of the pandemic i had
started
out of a fit of kind of futility and
feeling useless and somewhat bereft of
purpose
um i started this charity initiative
called the the plague nerd logs
which was i had a bunch of friends who
were actors who could not do the thing
that they do which is perform
and and i'm nerd and they're all nerds
and we all love nerd stuff
and there are certain passages and
speeches and monologues in the nerd
content that we all love i was like what
if some of these actors could perform
these things and i had inspired a bit by
the bbc had done
a bit uh i think was for like
shakespeare's 300th birthday or whatever
it was
they did a bunch of of shakespeare's
soliloquies and they would get like
chihuatel ejiofor and damien lewis and
like the finest british actors at work
to do you know hamlet and king lear and
and uh um i think the one that i think
damien lewis's was from julius caesar
which is beautiful it's gorgeous but
it's just them like in a camera and just
down the barrel just doing performance i
was like yeah it's like but what if we
did that for like nerd stuff yeah you
know what if what if we could get
somebody to do the you know a great
speech from plan of the apes or from
game of thrones or from you know
superman or from the marvel universe
whatever it was just find the things
that we all kind of love
and reach out to some actor friends
they're like yeah sure i'm not doing
anything
you know i've been self-taping auditions
so i got a camera and i got a backdrop
and i'll just lean into it
and you know we did it two cycles we did
one for no no kid hungry to raise money
for especially in the los angeles area
kids who could not go to school
and there were lots of kids who would
count on the food that they would get at
school because they just didn't have the
money at home to feed three meals a day
and then uh then black lives matter
broke out in the middle of the pandemic
and suddenly it became like oh well
let's raise some money for that and we
started a second wave of sort of a bunch
of new people and
and cast members and
the illuminati showed up to do this for
us
you know the craziest one was reaching
out to lin-manuel miranda oh you did and
uh and i'm being like
yeah okay what should i do and i sent
him the list of all the monologues he's
like i want to do i want to do commander
at dhamma from battlestar galactica and
i was like shut up
and like the next day it shows up in my
inbox it's like how was that is that
cool
um and so but we had gotten into contact
i don't even remember who connected us
but
phil lamar maybe or was it could have
been phil lamar it it could have been
kari i think kari payton yeah yeah yeah
i had done one
um and then you reached out but i think
we had already gone live with the second
wave and so it was if there's gonna be a
third wave can i do one and i was like
yes for sure
um but we like we raised something like
75 000 between the two
the two initiatives and so we didn't get
to do one but then we had a lovely phone
call yeah
just talking about it and talking about
the business and sort of our places in
it and you had you know a project that
you were trying to to generate and
and then that was the last time we spoke
and and because you then went back to
the walking dead
which i imagine swallows quite a bit of
time oh yeah the last season was 15
months straight oh my god that's a lot
of work there's a lot of zombies to kill
i killed so many zombies my hands are so
tired
yeah yeah um and then when you know norm
coyne who who runs this whole thing
related to the flaming lips um right up
there there he is yeah
yeah
there he is
oh you beautiful son of a [ __ ] um
he was like do you want to do another
black man beyond because last year i had
done one with ming chen um who is the
loveliest man in the world i'm sure he's
somewhere making somebody very happy
uh i don't know did ming run away to i
don't know make a wish come true or
something
i'm not sure
but then he was like well who's who's on
the list this year do you want to do
another episode of black man beyond and
it's scrolling down the list like
rocks
ross is the one i want to talk to i'm
honored because i
the thing that i love about being able
to do this is that i by and large do
with people who i like but have never
really met
and so getting a chance to know a person
in front of
strangers
friends i haven't met yet
um
seemed like fun and like as you can see
i have no questions in front of me i did
not come prepared
we are we are flying on the seat of our
pants
on a magic carpet ride yes
we're just gonna make dumb noises and
the thing is i'm i'm woefully out
clashed in the dumb noise category oh
yeah because you're like a professional
voice actor well i i heard you're doing
some voices last night i did the worst
obama last night
because like i think my obama got stage
fright because it was like oh yeah you
do obama in front of a professional
voice actor sure
that's fine i thought it was good either
it was all right yeah i'm not good
enough for government work but it'll
it'll get the job to slow your cadence
that's it just bring it down a little
bit yeah uh
yeah
uh michelle what i'm gonna tell you
about uh
the economy
will i find
illuminate
our
sexual lives it was a great listen he
was a great president but not as great
as the last president we had okay he was
a terrific terrific president we could
all agree on that right the greatest
president of all time right i mean we
could all agree
qrikets
for the kids for the kids we do lots of
trump for the kids
they love that i eat that right now
so so all right let's go all the way
back i wanna i wanna know the story of
ross i wanna know i don't know where you
came from the the pit of joy you clawed
free from the whose head you sprung like
athena from zeus's dome
i i was a test tube baby
uh i was harvested i was actually made
in a lab actually not too far outside
look much like wolverine i kind of uh
they infuse me with adamantium
uh no seriously i'm indestructible i'm
500 years old yeah this is all true so
you're a weapon why i'm weapon-wise
um
i love that wolverines from canada you
know because like
yeah but
canadians are the nicest people on the
planet i just love that like the most
angry bitter like
like violent person in all of marvel
universe is from canada it just makes no
sense to me well it spoke it speaks to
what americans did to him right like he
started he no he was he was formed in a
canadian lab was it was was alkali lake
in canada i think so i'm pretty sure i
was totally like upstate new york yeah
no no i'm pretty sure they were okay
because they were part of um
alpha alpha units alpha flight thank you
why would you do that to one of your own
yeah i mean i get why we would do it
because we're awful but americans are
awful but i mean why why was it
he wasn't polite he was impolite once
oh you weren't going to infuse you with
adamantium you how dare you
poor guy so yes clawed from the head uh
built in a lab
much like weapon x weapon a yeah
[Laughter]
from denver colorado youngest of three
boys
money was tight so
you know growing up and my parents used
to love johnny carson that was the only
guy that made them
get out of their heads because money was
really really tight for
most of
my yeah pretty much our whole life and
uh i said if i could sound like johnny
carson maybe i can make my parents laugh
and they won't
you know be all mad at us all the time
and um that's a all like art comes from
like pain and suffering like
i just want the pain to stop um so i did
johnny carson and that was the first
voice i ever did and it probably wasn't
very good but
just kind of went from there and yeah
good good enough to make him laugh yeah
exactly so was
was it the humor you were chasing at
some point or was it the performance you
were chasing at first it was just i want
the family to not fight all the time
because there was a lot of fighting uh
understandably because when money's that
tight like you know it's it's impossible
for the family dynamic not to be
a little tight a little uh you know
stressful um but then as time went on i
was like i would challenge myself to do
more and more impressions like john
travolta and when i was like 14 i used
to dress like him and go to school pulp
fiction was kind of weird phase okay i
mean better that than you know saturday
night fever
i feel would be weird in denver mid
1980s oh yeah speaking
of those lapels though yeah
yeah that's basically it you know that's
basically it an indoor i was an indoor
kid stayed home a lot talked to myself
still do really in denver you were an
indoor kid oh yeah you didn't i i went
outside but i also like
you went outside and found the indoors
outside exactly
watched a lot of adam's family bewitched
uh you know those old-time like 50s and
60s shows yeah that was my childhood um
so so after that and so what did your
parents what would your dad do what'd
your mom do mom was a school teacher
until she had us and then my dad sold
homes i'm sorry it was still hot uh he
sold homes until like seven or eight
years ago like 40 40 plus years yeah uh
now was playing in the like the model
homes the thing you got to do was it
like hey we're still in this house and
the residents have left and i got the
keys yeah yeah we got to play around a
lot of those it was fun yeah like high
school keggers like no i was a good kid
i was i was i was class president
actually i was really yeah what was your
platform
i'll make you laugh
i won't make anything better for you i'm
gonna make anything better i was like
i'll get a snack machine
maybe i didn't the [ __ ] promises you
make as a high school president exactly
like a lower taxes yeah we don't pay
taxes
but it worked so yeah it worked and so
now what are the benefits of being a
high school president nothing nothing at
all just a lot of work it was a lot a
lot of work not even like a security
detail no no security detail i i got
picked on if anything
i got more picked on because i was a
class president yeah
and so when did when did actual acting
show up in your life that
started in boy scouts when i was like
nine or ten i think and i used to do
campfire ceremonies and i would make fun
of some of the scout masters
and their voices and
that gotta laugh at a lot of people so
it's coming from there yeah
boy scout now how far did you make it
eagle oh you went the whole way
nice you did the thing when you had to
like send you out in the woods with a
with an orange and
an egg
i'm basically macgyver yeah
yeah so then you're the perfect dude for
the zombie apocalypse did any of that
stuff come in handy yeah are you kidding
me actually it's funny because
there's a scene from this season where i
have to tie a rope around me with one
hand because i have only one hand
spoiler and uh people yeah sorry
i lost my arm a few years ago if you're
not caught up yeah yeah no but uh
the the fans were like how could you tie
it with one arm and i was like well
there's a knot called the bowline knot
which i learned in boy scouts and you
literally don't need just using one hand
the rope to come down here and i
probably can't do it with this but you
basically do like one of these and then
you're gonna pull back on it and then do
that and it's done and that's enough
yeah and it's not
excellent yeah i'll teach you guys how
to do a bowl and not later if you want
yeah yeah thank you yeah thank you for
the applause for
my scouting paid off
that was a very good nut landing yeah um
i'm dad joking it like a mother today
you did a lot of that last night oh i
went hard i went hard
because that's how i go yeah hard okay
i'm also like still crazy tired and was
up too late last night and up too early
today so i'm like operating on fumes but
they're silly fumes yeah yeah silicone
is the best silly females are the best
yeah i was also a boy scout were you i
was how far did you go not that far okay
because it turned out
i uh i i went to boy scout camp summer
camp one year and i had a great time but
i was also like 15 years old and had
like just discovered
my dad's
porn stash
so showed up at boy scout your dad had a
porn stack he did he did he's like very
dirk diggler okay very like just
straight up just discovered it and then
you're like oh wait can i have that
and uh no i i i smuggled like three or
four playboy magazines to boy scout camp
and uh they politely asked me to not be
a boy scout anymore no way yeah oh man
yeah wow i mean i could have been great
you could have been you could have been
a contender
[Laughter]
alas i'm just now spoken of
it's all right man if it makes you feel
any better it's done very little for me
except for learning how to tie cool nuts
you know i mean i know where moss and
lycan grow and what to eat and what not
to eat see so you don't like mushrooms
though i don't know how to eat wild
mushrooms and you would not eat well i
mean i like mushrooms i don't i'm not a
fungi
uh okay so boy scouts is when you first
kind of like i i hate the term caught
the bug
because that is the worst
entertainment journalism cliche ever
when did you catch the acting bug
um it sounds like a disease but that was
the first time that you like performed
in front of people you were not related
to yes
and felt that charge of
oh damn this is cool yeah it's a nice
feeling when as i for the longest time i
wasn't sure if i wanted to do
film and tv or theater acting because
theater acting is much like this like
there's an immediate reaction like i
tell a joke and then you guys
go and that's a nice yeah thank you
that was really nice
that's nice there's some good walleye
yeah goodbye
i love those guys great band
um
but yeah i think that for me it was
always like nice to have that energy
that you can feed off of but uh for me i
prefer the the medium of filming tv to
theater in general why i just think you
can you don't have to ask them to go on
that
journey with you you can just show them
that there's a tank right here and you
can show them that there's this backdrop
because it's you're you're you're
showing them everything they need to see
with theater you have to ask the
audience to go on this ride with you you
have to like
ask them to use their imagination a lot
and i just feel like film and tv you
don't have to you can just show them
what you want to show them the buy isn't
as high
the buy isn't quite as high yeah yeah
okay i'll give you that
um
and so were you a nerd grown up was that
part of your matrix yes yes what what
what brand
not a deposition
yes
nerd yes nerd yeah yeah yeah
i was a marvel nerd okay i was first the
star wars nerd
uh still in yeah i read a lot of the um
uh the fiction like not the fan fiction
but the split during a mind's eye
i love admiral thrawn i think that he's
one of the most amazing and underused
characters in all the star wars universe
and i heard there's potential that he's
going to be in the new
boba fett or new mandalorian
ahsoka there's there's lots of ways for
him to appear exactly if y'all don't
know about thrawn you should look him up
he's kind of a badass um
but did you have like a hot 20 minutes
on thrawn
[Laughter]
i've got my master's thesis right here i
wrote it on the throne no but i used to
do like
lawn mowing and babysitting and all the
money that i made from that would go to
mile high comics in denver uh where i'm
from and i would just buy as many comics
and comic book cards as i could i have
marvel series one through three marvel
masterpieces a little bit of dz but dc
was never as exciting to me as marvel i
don't know i mean where you stand on
that but
well i i i don't know no no i am with
you but but my reasons were like i'm a
new yorker and i'm from new york and so
the idea that the comics that i was
reading took place in the same place i
was like i could go find the corner the
intersection in grants village where the
sanctum exemptorum is supposed to be
yeah yeah i could go to the leaker
street right leaker street i could go to
like 221
grey malkin lane which doesn't really
exist but upstate new york because i
tried to find it it's not there what is
that that's the x-mansion oh charles
xavier's school for the exceptionally
gifted um but like the baxter building
is somewhere in new york like all of
those things exist hell's kitchen is
real you know and so that for me like as
a kid who grew up in the bronx and lived
in long island and lived in queens the
idea that all of this was real was like
i know that metropolis is just supposed
to be new york and i know that gotham is
somehow also supposed to be in new york
or maybe new jersey which is this
shittier part of new york
um it makes sense but it just
it just didn't ground it for me the way
that marvel did like you could get on
the subway and maybe see spider-man yeah
in a way that you were never gonna see
batman and so i was always a marvel kid
like and then i switched not even switch
but then i like dark knight returns and
watchmen brought me into dc a little bit
yeah and then like the longbow hunters
the green arrow stuff and then ronin i
was i i became a writer follower and
said it was like frank miller i was
really a big fan of and then neil gaiman
i was a big fan of and then i would just
read everything that those guys did but
i was a marvel kid at heart like i was
an x-men kid and a spider-man kid who
was your favorite x-men
um
i think it's it's easy to say it was
wolverine because he was everybody's
favorite x-men i think the most
under-used x-men was storm
i was thought they never did quite
enough with her until they did there was
a whole run where chris claremont who
wrote i think the longest run that
anybody's ever had on the x-men did a
whole stretch when she lost her powers
oh wow and then it was
can can the storm goddess prove her
worth in the x-men without the lightning
without the thunder without the wind and
there's a great episode where she has to
challenge cyclops for leadership of the
x-men and she doesn't have any powers
and she kicks his ass oh wow because
cyclops i'm not sure if you guys know
this he's a punk
and so
yeah he's for sure just a punk and so
she just roundly kicks his ass and then
takes control of the x-men nice and so
like that that kind of stuff i just live
for but i think if i had to pick one
that i love the most i think was
nightcrawler
nice you know like just it's the circus
kid right it's like it's dumbo there's
the origin story of nikola is ultimately
dumbo as a kid i gravitated towards
wolverine and morph morph for me was
obvious because i was like oh i want to
be able to turn it into different people
you know it just seemed kind of like a
perfect superhero for me but wolverine
was always i mean come on you can't you
can't go wrong with logan you know um
you can and also as a short man i
respected logan quite a bit do you know
who the original casting was going to be
for for uh wolverine x-men to the 2001
with uh hugh jackman and everything do
you know who was actually up for that
that's exactly right
glenn danzig from the misfits and
obviously danzig he's like five six five
seven i think perfect and he just you
know built like a brick [ __ ] out so he's
like the dude was perfect for wolverine
i remember when when they cast hugh
jackman there was a big fan uprising
uproar oh yeah because he was too tall
and not canadian but
but the person they wanted
scott right well doug grace got shot for
a bit that's right that's right like he
actually but they it was one of those
marty mcfly things where they shot like
a couple of weeks with him like ah
that's not right not working out you
guys know what he's talking about
for back to the future yes that there is
that you can see it online that there's
there are scenes from back to the future
with eric stoltz as marty mcfly but eric
half the movie they showed yeah they
shot it quite a bit yeah but it was just
like he was good in it but everybody
realized that he's just not marty mcfly
for us like he's not the energy they
wanted they couldn't make happen doc
they needed that that michael j fox
vocal fried doc
whoa you say that we're going back to
1955. my god doc what is this plutonium
[Laughter]
it's amazing how much christopher lloyd
actually sounds a bit like an unhinged
al pacino which is basically
you know
they're not too dissimilar that's all
i'm saying you know
yeah this is gonna be a problem
see because i'm gonna do shitty jab dad
jokes and he's gonna do impressions
um but no the the fans wanted bob
hoskins
that was really yeah because i think
coming off of
who framed roger rabbit
it was like he's short he's hairy he's
stocky
that's my wolverine that's but he was
too old for that but he was way too old
yes he was wow yeah bob hoskins
wow if he'd put on some pounds he would
actually put a really good wolverine you
know he's he or a better puck or puck i
was gonna say puck yeah yeah he'd be a
great punk yeah i bet you're dana devito
somewhere it's like i could have done it
i'd have been great
at this good puck nowadays trying to
think a good i hope they do i hope they
do an alpha flight
movie i mean because honestly that stuff
the origin of wolverine they got touched
on a little bit in um
x-men origins wolverine the best of the
origins
not
the greatest but
it was still i mean that i remember
watching that as a kid being absolutely
terrified with with weapon x and that
that crazy thing he's got on that diaper
he's got in all the electrodes them and
they they finally get the adamantium
feed going and he just turns into this
raging monster the scariest diaper
what's that that's the scariest diaper
yeah it's scariest thing
you have a man running at you with claws
and a diaper you want to get out of that
guy's way
trust me trust me uh okay so so marvel
and star wars was your entree indeed
yeah entertainment star trek narration
too next generation
um thank you thank you nice nice engage
yes
that's my my my patrick picard always
turns into matt berry from what we do in
the shadows like yes of course engage
number one yes
it's not right at all jackie daytona
yeah
um
by the way side note have you guys seen
uh garth marangi's dark place
oh no it's the funniest thing ever
actually stephen king i think says it's
his favorite comedy and i couldn't agree
more it came out in 2004
noted
he's actually a big comedy fan stephen
king's like a huge comedy guy and he has
a good taste because uh you know gars
meringue is dark place it's on youtube
trust me it's the funniest thing i'll
ever watch yeah
you give me break blank stares but when
you watch it tonight you're gonna be
like he was right yeah like and tomorrow
they'll come by it's like ross
yeah dark place dark place
i got you garth marangi's dark place
okay all right um none of you are
writing this down so i'm very upset with
you okay yeah you are thank you thank
you thank you there it is thank you um
have you ever met stephen king no is he
cool
he uh i met him i met him once i was
working at entertainment weekly at the
time
oh yeah dalton ross says hi don ross the
sweetest lankiest guy i've ever met yep
he's a lovely man um but yeah i was
working entertainment weekly i was the
video as the dvd editor and i was
watching was in my office watching the
first season of battlestar galactica
which i just got on on dvd i'm just
sitting in my office and i look over
and stephen king is standing in my
doorway
and had been for like five minutes what
watching battlestar over my shoulder
and then i go
hey stephen king
what are you doing in my office is it
going because he was writing a column
for the magazine at the time so he made
his like annual visit to the staff to
make him feel like honestly was him
going to his publisher in new york from
maine and then he would take a detour to
ew and just hang out nerd out
and he's like hell of a show isn't it i
was like yes stephen king this is pretty
awesome i can only refer to him by both
names because it got weird
and and then he just sat there for
another 10 minutes and then he just
walked he went on his way and i was like
wow stephen king is kind of cool yeah
and i can only ever call him stephen
king i've heard he's actually a really
nice guy that people know where he lives
and he waves at people and like he's
very cordial and just like they leave
him alone but they he's like he's a part
of the town you know yeah so
it reminds me a bit of like i remember
hearing how dave chappelle lives in some
tiny town in like iowa no ohio ohio yeah
i'm sorry
but like once the town gets over the
fact that dave chappelle lives there
then he's just a guy who's going to like
basketball games for his kids and like
school meetings and all the
back-to-school night i think he's pretty
involved with the city council there too
from yeah yeah you know so i have to
imagine stephen king is a bit the same
way which is like i've been living here
for 98 years
and you all know who i am and once we
get over that i'm just a guy who's
living in a town who likes to shop at
the whole foods or whatever or the
piggly wiggly or the you guys have piggy
wheelies up here no okay tim horton it's
like a yeah
okay that's about the audience very nice
thank you it's that's very spinal tv
here all weekend to ingratiate yourself
to the crowd
hello cleveland
um okay star wars comic books
stephen king why i talked about stephen
king i don't know
um
do you remember you were talking about
my nerd
your nerd cred how you how you entered
into it
um
and so so being class president of the
eagle scout wasn't enough for you it
wasn't enough for you i should tell you
right there i'm a nerd
what kind of nerd are you pretty nerdy i
mean there's also like music theater
nerds yeah was that for a while too oh
nice yeah okay yeah what what was your
what's your favorite musical favorite
musical i don't really like musicals hot
take uh as a general rule i don't really
love music i love opera but i don't love
musicals but i like musicals that make
fun of themselves like urinetown or
avenue q love avenue q thank you for
that uh i heard
hamilton's amazing i haven't seen it
though it's quite astonishing really
yeah i recommend it okay i'm not gonna
watch it i mean but it's on like disney
plus of this yeah i'll just re-watch
loki i'm good
i'm already re-watching loki for the
third time like god i can't get enough
of this show so good um
okay okay any loki fans out there no yes
lovely
good good yes terrific
it's gonna be this all [ __ ] podcast
sorry
but then again we bought the ticket take
the ride um so uh boy scouts was your
big you're being like i want to be an
actor yeah
when did you actually get to be an actor
what was the what was the turn middle
school i did a bit of theater and uh
what are they called talent shows and
then um did the same thing in high
school and then by college i decided to
make that my major
where was college uh university colorado
boulder yeah
never leaving what was that never
leaving colorado just gonna stay there
it's a great great state
okay um so that was your major you
graduate
um magna [ __ ] laude
oh i'm not gonna no we're
we're polite in this house thank you um
so you graduate you've got your shiny
ass drama degree from university of
colorado boulder i was unemployed for a
decade after that
i did a lot of uh odd jobs to pay the
bills i did like uh medical studies
testing non-actually approved drugs on
my body i was a human guinea pig no joke
nice uh i did your weapon actually
what's that you are weapon x yes exactly
i'm like just waiting for like a claw to
just pop out of me somewhere but it
wouldn't be anywhere cool it would be
somewhere like on the back of my neck
come over here so i can stab you
got an armpit claw yeah
you turn the christopher walken over
there oh wow well i had i had walking on
the brain because he just got cast in uh
dune part two what are you a dune fan
i'm a huge dune fan he's playing the
emperor saddam iv
oh my god right wow but is he gonna
walking it up though can he not walk in
a spice
it's gotta flow
if you wanna bend time and space you
gotta get the spice
i'm telling you a lot of tradies
household conan it's no good
trust me okay yeah watch that
i like to turn to trump
believe me it's gonna be the greatest
deal in the history of the federation
the spice will flow so good it's gay
um but yes so 10 years unemployed yes um
what what broke it for you walking dead
yeah yeah that was the first break i had
that was eight years ago but uh yeah i
had a hundred and fifteen thousand
dollars worth of debt nice i was in deep
deep [ __ ] as they say and then i gave up
acting i literally said i need to walk
away from this it's not gonna happen for
me uh i had auditioned for the show
twice already and i said well i guess
this isn't gonna happen and that's okay
you know i was like i'm gonna move on to
something else and
then that month went by and my manager
called me at the blue i hadn't heard
from her for probably seven or eight
months i thought they had dropped me
honestly i just like oh you guys still
rep me okay and like we got an audition
for the walking dead tomorrow i was like
oh
thank you but i
i'm not acting anymore and she's like
what i'm like yeah i don't act anymore
and she's like you're going to this
audition we worked really hard to get
you this i was like okay and then it was
the only time i didn't care about the
outcome
in my life and i mean that sincerely
like
the lesson because people like never
give up on your dreams i'm like well i
did
and
that's the lesson i think there is
don't
don't attach yourself so much to the
idea that like you will only be happy if
you have this job or this career or this
uh girlfriend or boyfriend or whatever
like
make sure that you are just open to
whatever the universe throws at you and
just go for the ride because i think for
years i was like if i don't if i'm not a
successful actor i failed as a human
being
and that's a terrible way to look at
your life you know um
so so yeah i just i really feel like
it's important to just kind of take the
pressure off yourself and just let the
universe decide where you're going to go
a little bit to some degree you know
in the ross marquan multiverse of
madness yes
what is the life you would have led had
walking dead not called you back i love
carpentry i love building
wood i love working with wood and
everything and then i just really kind
of wanted to do that and photography so
so you would have been like
you'd made the late career push to
become harrison ford before he becomes
han solo like i just want to build
somebody's house man i forgot that's
right he was he was a it wasn't like a
set
builder for for
he he built i want to say it was like
i think so but i think he built jerry
garcia's studio
in san francisco and i think he built
like carly simon's house or whatever
like he was just a guy who built stuff
and also got people weed
oh that's right he was he was the weak
guy a huge weed smoker like has been for
like 50 years yeah yeah but there's some
quote so funny because he's such an
angry man
i don't know any wheat smoker who's like
that angry
imagine if he didn't have weed jesus
you're off on my lawn get out of here
kid i don't care what you smell you big
dumbo
get out of here
bring me back my green
[Laughter]
i would watch that show but yeah just
harrison before getting high all the
time i'd watch the [ __ ] out of that show
there was some quote that like mama cass
went to go see star star wars and was
like that's my weed guy
yeah like that's what he did he built
houses and got weed for anybody who was
performing in the bay area wow which wow
wow
so great wow i love that i love that
journey for him
you start as a weed guy and then you
build houses and now you're a big actor
that's amazing wow
wow
love that guy um all right so
you can't turn me off i'm sorry it just
it happens and then yeah well i do
appreciate that you're not like the
person who does impressions that doesn't
want to do impressions oh yeah you know
like
like
you're you're peter dinklage in the elf
movie where you're like listen i got one
or two good impressions they're really
good but i don't do them i don't just
get out of [ __ ] band unless you're
gonna pay me my money do you you want to
hear the trump pay me you want to hear
you want to hear it harrison ford cost
you
i would never
for free gratis
um okay so walking dead hits yes
um and i suppose it would be uh uh an
understatement to say that it changes
your life yeah yeah what's the weirdest
way in which it changed your life um
just just
being
spotted you know that that i'm still
very private individual so like you know
i eat very sloppily i'm kind of like a
messy eater like i'm always like
you know and so people are like taking
pictures of you while you're
then you get tagged on instagram
and the beard doesn't have flattering
yeah there's a tomato in the beard
oh i just turned into gollum
no that's one of the orgs goodbye yeah
uh so yeah it's just weird it's still
like because i was a fan of the show
before i got on it so
it's just a weird like surreal thing to
be like oh you
wanna meet me you wanna it's which is
weird you know i don't know i just never
thought i'd be someone that people would
want to meet you know really yeah i mean
that's not like an astrological thing
but
as a person who wanted to be a performer
that must have been a thing that you
knew or hoped would happen never hoped
but just a possibility but yeah i just
like acting you know i you know
oh yeah
there never was a that was never a draw
for me if anything that was a deterrent
right but like you like it's weird
because in success you know it'll happen
what in success you know it would happen
right i suppose so yeah yeah if i'm
gonna get on a tv show or a movie and
i'd love people to see it and if that
happens if i become a person who gets to
do this job regularly yeah i just
thought i was always gonna be a
voiceover guy who
worked in a booth all the time and no
one ever recognized because you never
recognized the voice
and you know or the face of someone
doing voice you know so that was going
to be my trajectory and then i got this
audition so and then you got famous yeah
sorry sorry
sorry kid
didn't mean it did mean to but now
you're on the apprentice season five
it's a great i'm sorry like my default
setting is now trump i'm like i'm really
sorry
but i'm not sorry okay
because it's the greatest impression
i've ever done believe me
it's it's the belief belief of the
swallowing
um what's the coolest thing that being
on the walking dead has allowed you to
do uh
well
stuff like this honestly i mean i've
gotten a chance to go to brazil japan
lithuania prince george
uh and honestly it's just it's it's a
neat thing to go all over the world and
and meet people because i like nerding
out about this stuff as much as anyone
else so for me it's it's just it's a joy
i love it you know i really do during
the pandemic it sucked not being able to
do these you know it really sucked very
much so so because that's the thing
about nerds right like we want to be
able to talk to other nerds about the
thing that we love
and if you can't do that
then you die we die
we lose our purpose
we lose our purpose um all right we're
gonna we're gonna prep for some q a if
anybody has any questions for either of
us um i do just want to take a second to
acknowledge uh the passing of somebody
who i discovered today
the great fred ward
no yeah
if yeah he of tremors of
you know a thousand different things
cast a deadly spell was the first time i
saw him this amazing hbo movie um remo
williams the adventures of rhema
williams uh the right stuff
thurman um
uh oh yeah topic of cancer uh
don't i know exactly what you mean it's
like punch and judy
yeah iris and henry and iris henry yes
and henry in june every june yeah yeah
we got there yeah all right thanks
thanks everybody um but uh but no he was
it's funny i saw a tweet today that said
that fred ward walked so that john
bernthal could run oh that's a great
you know wow
you know i never
god that's so accurate but if you look
at those two guys and like what they
were and what they represented there was
just this kind of rugged masculinity but
also a deep well of emotion about them
yeah you know and physicality they were
they're both incredibly physical actors
they look a lot alike too the sh the
fact that we don't we don't get the
opportunity to see them as father and
son yeah which would have been amazing
that would have been amazing but yeah
fred ward was a character actor he was a
movie star he was a performance
performer he was a comedian he was a
dramatist
um he was the kind of actor that we
don't produce that much anymore and so
his loss is deeply felt if you're a nerd
or if you if you liked
great great movies yeah and even some
bad bad movies because it was a bad
movie i mean he was never bad in them
that's true
yeah but then i think they brought him
back for like the the generations
collide it was the generations
of tremors movies where it's like the og
showed up and then the new crew was
there
chicken wing it was tremors the new
batch yeah the new bag yeah yeah
um but yes so uh rest in peace fred ward
you will not be forgotten
um
so yes we got a couple questions i think
we have another hour to go i'm kidding
we have as much time as we'd like but
uh gentlemen what can we answer for you
hello uh i'm i'm really selfish i love
when i hear people do impressions and uh
you were mentioning the plague nerd
alongs which is a fantastic thing you
can hear online uh i love them uh rob
benedict uh did one for patrick bateman
which i absolutely love is my favorite
one so i was wondering if each of you
can pick a monologue that the other
person has to do and in a voice that the
other person has to do that's more of a
request than a question oh wow well
what monologues do you do because it'd
probably be easier if we just i do i do
like hamlet i do a celebrity from hamlet
that's i could do that
i could i could do i could do the
snippet from henry the eighth i could do
the
we few we happy few i like that um
so now the trick is one of us can do
voices
and one of us cannot um
so i think i'll if you want to do hamlet
which one is it to be or not to be no i
was gonna do uh well he's about to kill
felonious
okay he's praying no fair enough um
let's see
how can you do claudius sorry claudius
can you do that
as william shatner sure
now might i do it past now he's praying
and now i'll do it so he goes to heaven
and so am i revenged i i don't think
he's not he's not the best one for me i
gotta do maybe like gonna do jeff
bridges yes okay
uh now might i do it pac-man
the dude is praying right now and and
now i'll do it and so
he goes to heaven and stolen my revenge
man yeah nice
um
let me see if i can offer
you guys because you can ask like i'd
like you to do that as ruth buzzy i'm
like i don't have a good ruth buzzy
very shitty ruth buzzy um let's see um i
can try it as i can try this denzel
we'll see if we can get denzel to happen
all right all right
we few we happy few week band of
brothers
for he today who believes with me shall
be my brother
yeah is that all right yeah
i got there
very nice
plymouth rock didn't land on us
you've been hoodwinked
you've been swaddled
you been took yeah what did you gotta do
what's your favorite denzel movie of all
time
um i
once a year i watched glory i was just
gonna say gloria once here i watch glory
glory is a phenomenal movie
so good which even though it's weirdly
about the white guy
but also not that weirdly because it was
made in hollywood in 1986
so like yeah let's make it about matthew
broderick we've got the finest black
actors in the world yeah it's gonna be
about that guy
but even still i think it's it's it's a
masterpiece yeah like and then the the
final push against fort wagner is what
andre brown andre brauer and
denzel and and
morgan freeman
the great carrie elwiz morgan freeman oh
my god
that man could read me the the bible and
i would love i don't know he would be a
dictionary he would read me the
dictionary and i would love it i love it
very much
you walk through eight miles of [ __ ]
and a dufferin
we were actually we were talking the
other night about the stephen king
dollar baby thing yes which i think you
all i have a feeling that some of you
may know what that is which is stephen
king um
has a boatload of short stories and
novellas and stuff like that and he
would always get these these questions
from filmmakers especially young ones
how do i get the rights to a stephen
king book to make a movie out of
and if you were a a student filmmaker or
a young filmmaker an indie filmmaker he
would give you the rights to a novel or
a short story for a dollar provided that
you don't intend to make any money off
of that short film you can enter in
festivals you can screen it for free you
go to schools or whatever but you
couldn't make a dime off of it if you
did then you have to actually buy the
rights like if so if some studio wants
to buy it then you enter the actual
agreement with us talk to my agent it's
going to cause you x
but
frank darabont
got on stephen king's radar by making a
dollar baby really by making a tiny
short which then encouraged stephen to
let him do shawshank which then led to
green mile and then a few years later
leads to the walking dead wow but that
was that was his path wow um i don't
know why i decided to tell a story i
guess because we're talking about andy
dufresne
my friend andy dufresne he was the
wisest man i've ever seen in my life
his skin was translucent i've never seen
anything like it
see right through the man he's like
powder
and with that movie
sean patrick fanery
anyway
um
okay so i think i did did we satisfy
your question yes you did thank you also
i'll throw a shout out because uh a
dollar baby project was shot here
locally the doctor's case
that's right which was spearheaded by
our own norm coin exactly
once again
love fur rafters
uh you got it man thank you
hello sir hello hello another fred ward
role that uh doesn't get depreciated
enough is uh miami blues he plays the
stranger ranger danger and now oh yeah
oh nice but no question uh one for each
of you ross what did the your theater
background uh put into your actors
toolkit for when it is time to you know
act for uh television and film
versus the live stage as you mentioned
and then well
so how did that prepare me for filming
yeah like what did that live environment
put into your your toolkit as an actor
and a performer i think the best thing
was just the the work ethic of it all uh
because i will say
you can kind of tell theater actors from
film and tv actors pretty quickly like
andy lincoln who played rick
he he had that ethic of just like no we
are classically trained actors we are
going to show up first thing work our
asses off he didn't drop character ever
the only time i heard him drop character
was it was
my second day of shooting on the show
where he had to punch me in the face
and
25 takes in a row
no problem he missed my nose by this
much on the last take
he fully clocked me in the nose and he
got like the whole nose and i and i'm
telling you like i just like i dropped
on the ground like this
and
he went from being like yeah yeah are
you all right yeah yeah yeah oh my god
i'm so sorry mate you're all right and i
was like
anything can work because i think it was
it was like
i just got punched by rick grimes that's
cool yeah but no like uh
just the most professional kindest man
if you ever get a chance to meet andrew
lincoln he's the best best person period
um but i think that kind of like
uh discipline work ethic you know that
all informs it i don't think
the thing i had to learn was getting
smaller because film and tv
the you know the cameras right here you
don't have to you know play to the to
the stands or whatever so it's actually
i had to unlearn a lot of stuff because
i was always like hello how are you sir
yes are you up there can you hear me you
know i just turn into
matt berry every time i do a theater gag
and i'm okay with that yes shakespeare
best writer ever
fax not true um
yeah so yeah that's a answers your
question yeah absolutely cool just for
mark obviously uh less uh voice acting
and performance question more about uh
writing where does uh you mention
growing up in new york where does uh
conan the barbarian fit into your stew
and where does that come into and then
just two part because i'm here at the
mic uh season two notwithstanding uh if
you were to pick a revelations character
that's gonna get their own happy days
joni loves chachi spin-off who would
that be
not including man at arms okay
uh
deep cuts but got it um so conan the
barbarian i have i have a deep and
abiding love for that character
um and a lot of it stems from the fact
that
there was a summer i want to say was my
sophomore into junior year of high
school where
no no i'm wrong it was my
um graduating junior high so 8th grade
into 9th grade i was changing schools
but i did not do great
in school i was a historically poor
student
um
yeah no it's some of it was i didn't
care um some of it was i just got bored
um and some of it was i just wasn't
engaged with it to a certain degree so i
had a string of d's and f's
was graduating out of junior high into
high school and so then i took it upon
myself uh
to be the first 13 year old master
forger
and attempted to
with a with a ballpoint pen
turn those f's into a's
and those d's into b's i would add a
little extra bump in there
and like bring it home to get my parents
to sign so i can then take it back to
school and then erase the adjustments i
made because the big innovation whatever
this was 1986 was erasable pens
um
needless to say
i was not the 13 year old master
criminal that i thought i was and i got
busted and my the punishment for that uh
flagrant disregard of the rules was
i could not leave my room for the summer
like the only places i could go were the
bathroom the kitchen and the library
wow and so i got to like watch my
friends like walk up and down the street
as they went to the to the high school
to play basketball or ride their bikes
or chase their balloons or whatever they
were doing and i was in my room and i
spent that summer reading like that's
the summer i learned to love reading
and one of the books that i that i
started to read was the conan wrote the
roberty howard conan the barbarian
novels because i was a huge conan comics
fan i was like oh these come from novels
or they made novels of the comic books
great
and the thing that i found in those
books it's it's very similar to my x-men
journey was
conan was an outsider conor was a guy
who was born into a village in the
middle of samaria which is i guess like
norway meets scandinavia or whatever but
his skin was a little bit darker than
everybody else his eyes were bluer than
everybody else like he was bigger than
everybody else and he just didn't fit in
and so everywhere that he went he was
the guy that they were sort of you never
fit in tough being so jacked and so
beautiful i mean you know not everybody
can be a jack australian and make it
work
but that feeling of being out of place
that feeling of being an outsider that
feeling of being
the person who was a little too big for
the rooms that he was in
which was very much my experience
growing up as
a black dude who liked nerd [ __ ] who
played dmd who was also on the football
team but liked architecture i want to be
an architect for a stretch
you know and i'm not a small man
and so and even today like i'll walk
into rooms in hollywood and my job is to
defuse the bomb that
isn't going to go off yet is to make
people comfortable
with me and who i am and so conan was
very much this avatar for that and this
idea of the outsider as a hero this idea
of a person who had a code of honor that
was instilled in him
almost by accident and experience and
and failures of his own life less the
the vagaries of a world that would
impress upon him its own morality but
there was just a lot about that
character that i responded to um
and they all always tickled me just a
little bit when i discovered that robert
e howard was a crazy racist
um
yeah the writer was yeah very much a
white supremacist
um i mean he wrote he's a dust bowl guy
from the 1930s and so it doesn't
necessarily not that every dust bowl
person in the 30s was awful but when i
hear that one is it doesn't surprise me
that much
um but yeah like like him and
um what's his face the cthulhu guy
lovecraft hp lovecraft
was it yeah a lot of those stories are
about like
the pure breeding of blah blah blah and
getting rid of the darker parts of the
blue blue did you see lovecraft country
i did so you love that it makes a lot of
sense which yeah it's very much like
like a big middle finger to who h.p
lovecraft was to make a show that's all
about black people inheriting this kind
of power have you all seen that by the
way love crop country oh yeah no it's
amazing it's remarkable watch that show
there's there's three or four episodes
of that that are my favorite episodes of
tv i've seen in a long time
so that was my conan journey it was very
much about you know in the same way that
the x-men were very much about
teenagers who didn't know what to do
when their body started to get weird and
how people would respond to that
weirdness of their bodies um as well as
like hey we just don't like nightcrawler
why because he's blue and we're not all
about that blue life
um so yeah it's it's i think when we
come to the things we love there's
always a personal part of it for us it
always it strikes a chord that
harmonizes with us who we are inside or
who we would like to be inside and so
conan was was very much like that for me
if there was a massive universe
revelation spin-off that i would want to
do
um
i think i want to do a misunderstood
opera about triclops
triclops like he's just a guy with three
eyes
you know like
but people keep on thinking he's bad
because the one eye is always wrong it's
not reflecting how he feels i'm still
disappointed you guys didn't cast me as
man at arms
i mean i have i have one arm on my eye
i think i'm a shoe-in for that you're
well mad at arm once we get there
[Laughter]
um
tell me um
what's your question young camper hello
uh first off thanks for coming this has
been awesome
thanks for having us for sure i just
have a two-parter if it's okay by all
means thank you he did a two-parter
we've opened the gates
ross what was it like to bring the red
skull back into the marble universe with
the avengers and whatnot and for both of
you i was just wondering um with the
multiverse opening up now with marvel
is there um any storyline or characters
that you would like to see be brought in
yes
oh okay i'll answer the first yeah yeah
so yes you go first man i real quick i
love
the character nightmare because he has
like nightmare he doesn't know
nightmares okay thank you whoever did
that yeah he got a will in the back oh
nice yeah i i just feel like
that character
if if anyone's gonna open up the
multiverse and
spring some really crazy visuals on us
like the last few spidermen have been
fantastic because they've really leaned
into and the first doctor strange and
certainly the last doctor strange as
well leaning into that like kind of
trippy ethereal world which i find
fascinating because i'm i'll be honest i
don't want to see another superhero
movie where people just beat the crap
out of each other for two hours i i
think we have to really stretch the
genre a lot to keep it interesting you
know and you bring in characters like
nightmare who can literally tap into
your psychic energy while you're
sleeping
very you know you know friday the 13th
or no i mean uh nightmare before
nightmare elm street type of [ __ ] like
that i think
could really open up the
multiverse in a big way and i think they
might i've heard rumors they might bring
him into it which would be amazing who
knows but um he'd be a character i'd
love to see in that and uh red skull was
kind of interesting they they called me
this was like five years ago yeah uh my
manager college said do you do a huge
weaving impression and i said what hugo
weaving because like the guy's like the
master of impressions in accents you
know he's australian but he does all
these different accents
and they said well we can't really tell
you what it is but it's it's a german
hugo weaving i'm like oh so like red
school and they're like well we can't
really say like they're talking about
red school and they sent me the clip and
of course it was from captain america
first avenger and uh i'd never tried it
but i listened to it a few days and then
i sent in my audition didn't hear
anything for like a month we had just
finished filming season
eight i think
and i had just flown back from georgia
to la and i was in my uber home
and uh my manager called me like halfway
through the drive and she said hey um
you booked that marvel thing and i was
like whoa oh cool what was that what was
it for and she's like hey they they
won't tell us what the project is
seriously like they they didn't tell us
the project until i got there and it was
called mary lou was it was it was the
that was the uh code name
and i remember that she said you're
still in atlanta right i'm like no i
just got to like say oh they need you
there tomorrow so like get right back
you know it's a five and a half hour
flight so i go right back to the airport
book the next flight out get there like
one or two in the morning wake up four
hours later and then i'm on set
and you know then i realized pretty
quickly this is not some small little
thing this is a huge production because
there's 150 people waiting for me and
they put me in the mocap suit and
everything and
it was a trip because that's a character
that used to draw as a kid he used to
draw him uh omega red mephisto
ghost rider basically any like character
that was like scary looking in skull
really related i was really big with
that because i was wasn't still in kind
of like a punk i suppose
you know a punk fan yes all things goth
and dark i i like uh so
yeah that's that's that was a really
surreal moment going from like this is
my childhood to them being able to play
a character that i love so much it was
uh it's it's still i'm still pinching
myself because it's it's been it's been
a joy really yeah you did awesome thank
you thank you man thank you
um
okay what storylines characters would i
want to see in the multiverse i'll tell
you what i was disappointed has
everybody seen doctor strange too
probably not electric boogaloo
okay yeah
um i won't tell you i mean i gather you
all have seen a trailer or two and you
know there is a sequence where the
illuminati show up
i am not going to say who's on the
illuminati because if you haven't seen
it i'll leave that as a spoiler for you
i will tell you however the person that
i wanted to see who was not there
i really really really wanted to see
wesley snipes as t'challa oh because
wesley snipes tried to make a black
panther movie did he really for about 10
years
like in the 90s like coming off of like
demolition man and passing 53
pre like i think it was just like it was
pre-blade he wanted to do it but it took
him forever and then blade comes out and
he's a huge movie star
but it was one of those like stanley had
sold enough of the rights and scattered
them to the winds that there was a there
was a rights issue and nobody knew and
like black superheroes in wakanda and
this is all weird but he desperately
wanted to be t'challa wow and so in the
world in which we're doing multiversal
stories
and we're also seeing you know at least
in no way home various interpretations
of the same character yeah like to see
wesley snipes sitting on a throne as
t'challa with the gray beard and
everything
would be amazing are you excited for my
hershell to play blake i am so i mean
i'm so down he is such an amazing actor
um
you know and i and i love that we're now
in this sort of horror zone yeah with
marvel that they're just digging deep
like moon knight and doctor strange and
you know i would love to see a ghost
writer another version of ghost right
thank you but like do it right though do
it right right get into it i don't
necessarily need nicholas cage pissing
fire
um as cool as that is don't get me wrong
like nicolas cage pissing fire i'm gonna
steal the declaration of independence
and piss on it okay
take my face off why didn't you do that
in the movie that was a that was that
was a perfect opportunity for him to go
my face just came off and i was a skull
okay i remember
i remember reading this quote from the
guys who did um spider-man into the
spider-verse um and uh and he was
talking about working with nicolas cage
and they kept they were in the sound
booth and they're doing the voice
recordings and the the director kept on
saying like listen nicholas can we get
like i don't know ten percent more i was
like okay ten percent more and he's like
okay more yeah the temperature more so
okay and they go again it's like listen
can we get a little bit more
and he'd say oh so you want the full
cage
the fact that that's how he refers
like you want the full cage
oh
okay
not the beer
by the way if you guys haven't seen
there's a super cut on youtube called
nicholas cage
losing his [ __ ] i think we're spelled
you know
yeah the editors
henry o'halloran or something like that
it is the funniest four or five minutes
of your you will witness trust me
nicholas cage losing his [ __ ] you will
love it just after this look it up for
sure yeah it's amazing yeah um
so great hey man hey bud have you a
question for us i just have one question
for ross uh
what's it like to play a character
closer to the mic sorry yeah what's it
like to play a character who to his core
is probably one of the most decent human
beings but stuck in situations where he
has to kind of go against his very brain
like what he's a red skull right oh no
he's a good guy yeah
uh it's funny because i think
the first few seasons on walking dead i
was getting a bit frustrated because
he he was too nice for his own good you
know and he every community he got uh he
interacted with even rick in the gang
from the beginning
just beat him up rick beat him up the
heapsters beat him up the oceansiders
beat him up the saviors beat him up
every single group he the the whispers
every single group he interacts with
they're just like this guy's too nice we
gotta beat the crap out of him you know
and i feel like
by season
eight i was really you know reaching out
to the writers and saying hey
you gotta you gotta let this guy fight
back a little bit you know cause right
now it's
it's just kind of silly that he's he's
that nice given everything going on and
i need to know that this guy's gonna get
a little bit darker and and they took
that note and they really went with it
which i'm so grateful for uh because
otherwise i think it would have been a
very one-note character you know um but
they really let me lean into the dark
aaron or as chris hardwick says the
darren
which i
tried to get that trending on twitter
didn't happen but yeah that's it i'm
sorry sorry one day darren will be yeah
[Music]
that's awesome you do a great job thank
you thank you very much thank you
raise
hey man hello how are you i am doing
well that seemed guarded
i'm doing
well checking
well
what can we do for you sir i have
questions
well then by all means answers yes all
right so one question for mark and one
for ross
um so mark um
so we're still talking about multiverses
and preparing characters um since i
asked you earlier about star trek picard
uh we were all pleasantly surprised to
see will win come back um on to
star trek in general and that was too
well guarded secret that just kind of
blew us all by the wayside
um
how did the idea bring him back and
visiting him as a traveler
come about
um if i remember correctly i remember
being in the writers room just talking
it was very
early on in the process and just blue
skying you know which is my favorite
part of writing which is
here's five or six or seven people all
engaged to to create this season of
television but before we're even talking
about episodes before we're talking
about scenes before we're getting
granular about it it's what could happen
what could we do what could this be
and i think there was always the idea of
bringing back
you know members of the original next
generation cast i mean it's it is
ultimately picard is as a television
show
is
i'm not gonna say it's purely nostalgic
because you know absolutely patrick
stewart is one of our finest actors and
and you can 100 give new adventures for
a character like that and have them
resonate have them mean a lot but
there's also the people who came to him
first in the next generation or
gurney halligan dune
but
so the idea of being able to to use some
of those past characters those past
stories to inform the present story was
pardoned it was baked into the season
and then it was like well we saw we saw
diana and we saw riker in season one um
we knew that beverly was going to play a
bit of a role in season two given it was
all gonna be about love it's gonna be
about
john luke's uh incapacity to connect to
commit to other people
um
then what what of his past can we use
what touchstones have we have we not
been able to overturn from next
generation and the idea of will wheaton
of wesley crusher will wheaton
as a as a traveler well when did we last
him will we last so i'm just vanishing
into the stars as a new member of this
cosmic race or whatever
it always just kind of like it was one
of those cards on the index board index
cards on the board whatever you get it
um
cars on the board that was always kind
of exciting of like we don't know what
we're gonna do with it yet but wouldn't
it be cool if we could bring back wesley
crusher you know there's there's some
portion of these i think you find it a
lot in star wars at this point star wars
tv
where it seems as if
it's a it's a reclamation project for
the prequels in a way
in the
you know we know you didn't love these
things
but
i think they're cool and let me show you
why i think they're cool let me show you
how
they were better than potentially you
don't remember or recognized at the time
and so the idea of
leaning deep into the clone wars and and
bringing ahsoka back and bringing boba
fett back and bringing suddenly the idea
that like it's at one point darth maul
was going to be the bad guy of kenobi
but that's not happening but it's
yeah there was a season where darth maul
yeah keep going no no keep going was
gonna be the bad guy and then i think
that there had been a slight change in
course and then it became vader's the
bad guy the inquisitors and all that but
the idea that the prequels are not as
bad as we might have thought they were
and to be fair there's an entire
generation of kids who are now adults
for whom that was their star wars
and that is and that is not a thing to
be taken lightly which is when you come
to this is when it's yours
and i came to star wars as an
eight-year-old kid uh coming to a new
hope for the first time some people the
correct way the correct way yes you know
there are some kids who came to it in
the 90s with the prequels the incorrect
way
there's somebody who came to it with the
sequel also the incorrect way we don't
speak of that
yes the ruling has been handed down
um
and but each of those are valid for
those people and their emotional bond
and commitment to those characters is
not insignificant so the idea of
bringing anakin skywalker brac i'm
bringing hayden christensen back
as vader as as that character is that
happening yeah
what
where have you been what
is this just
for the for kenobi for kenobi yeah i
didn't know that i watched a trailer and
everything i'm i'm sorry you're supposed
to be the chosen one anakin yeah they
haven't seen much they're mindful of the
force yes
my favorite though is i have the high
ground
which is like
you can do backflips and you can
literally levitate i mean it's kind of
ridiculous yes
i look when he chops his legs off he's
like well you're [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then he just keeps climbing
well i have to go now you know you're a
total prick yes
i'm going to pick up this life to save
your life but you're an absolute nuns
don't mind me i'm just going to grab
this lightsaber
i'm not even going to polish it off
30 years from now give it to your son
and not tell him you killed like 40 kids
with it
yes this was your father's his murder
weapon
how many children died with this my
favorite i watched the
attack of the clones in germany when it
first came out
i was visiting next and that's just
happened to me when it came out and it
was called angry deconglica that's what
the
that everything sounds more badass in
german but it was all in in subtitles
but i remember
that scene where the sand where anakin's
like i hate sand it gets everywhere
i killed them all the women and the
children too it's just the most emo
delivery and i was like that to me i was
like i will never forget that scene for
as long as i live where i was sitting
having a beer and an ice cream at this
german movie they're like ah this is
such a moment you know it's amazing you
know like i'll never forget that scene
it's longer to live it's just so good
neither will most of us yeah that's true
yes indeed um but all of that is to say
that that there's always a part of
especially legacy
genre media where people come to
different parts of their lives and they
attach themselves to different places of
it i remember hearing that will wheaton
was not that big a fan of his experience
playing wesley crusher yeah because i
think some of it
will
we do
um i mean
he was a teenager like going through all
the things that a teenager goes through
playing a character that nobody on star
trek fandom seemed to like because
i was down with wesley because wesley
was supposed to be every 15 year old
watching star trek for the first time
except that he also got into lots of
trouble that kept on causing them to
like
all right i guess we'll take the ship to
save wesley again with ashley judd with
ashley judd
um so yeah the idea of like let's make
wesley crusher integral to the story and
make us love him again and make us sort
of re-evaluate who that character was
and see where he is on his own journey
of living and developing and seeing the
universe in ways that our characters
never could there was always the thing
that was like just on the wall
and so the fact that that we actually
did get to sort of dovetail around and
finish that story off a little bit
was really kind of lovely um and i can't
wait for season three because season
three you know i i am not in that room
so i don't know exactly what they're
doing but the fact that they got almost
the entire next generation cast back
is like yes please oh they got them all
i did not know that either
i i feel as if she's kind of busy man i
know you're making [ __ ] zombie stuff
but
like but yeah like
everybody i think everybody but it's
like wharf and riker denise
oh no sadly not that version the
multiverse um she can come back as some
priscilla maybe very true yeah
if you ever get a chance to meet denise
crosby she's amazing great
great person
so yeah yeah then she was here a couple
years ago right yeah yeah yeah it's
really yeah so i would like to do that
she's awesome can you make that happen
who knows denise crosby will get denise
because i can leave now yeah yeah
i have her cell phone number if you want
to call her
hello
i have no plans on calling you denise
the world is like you become a hannibal
i just went straight to
denise rhymes with clarice so we're
doing lecter now
i have the most simple mind in the world
um
does that answer your question sir it
does
equate to a question for ross which
apparently you didn't have as much free
time as i thought you did
free time
now the walking dead is over but yeah um
how are you working with that um tron
musical redo oh wow that was a deep cut
glad you uh what is this explain so
in because going back to what we talked
about before i was very vocal about not
being the biggest musical fan in college
i was like these are so cheesy and
they're dumb you know there's only a few
that i really like and a friend of mine
who was in the bfa with me she said you
think musicals are so easy why don't you
write one and i was like okay ben i will
and
i couldn't think of what i wanted it to
be about but i did it for the boulder
fringe festival which was the kind of
french we did every year at university
of colorado and um
i was getting high because i live in
colorado one night and i was watching
one of my favorite movies tron
and my buddy and i were watching it and
i told him the whole thing he's like you
should ride a musical of tron i was like
i should
and i did and to this day
my
by far greatest achievement doesn't
matter what i do for the rest of my life
writing tron the musical with eight
original songs
fully rehearsed with black lights and i
made the costumes with my friend
brittany and we like put all this like
fluorescent tape and paint on there and
like it was it looked it looked you know
miniature golf like in the 90s was all
fluorescent it was like that but like
all black light everywhere it was
amazing so like cosmic bowling but for
tron precisely yeah excellent which is
basically the whole premise of tron
they're like yeah we'll do cosmic bowler
but i had life as an arcade sarks lament
i had uh whatever songs they have uh uh
the cycle of light
all these like
yeah i know yeah thank you for that is
there an album that i can download
there's a there's a dvd i have of it at
home i could probably upload that to
youtube it's pretty bad qual it's 2003
or 2004. pretty bad do it dude
we demand it
drop this is like my dream come true
i've always wanted
this oh no no no i just directed and
wrote it i never it wasn't in it so i i
put my musical theater friends in that
because i don't know how to sing but
yeah but i'm going to sing later
apparently karaoke tonight well
but then you should do a tron song
i'm sure they'll know how to play it
i am the master control program yeah oh
that was kind of a devo see i was going
that was nice
yeah yeah very nice thank you we like to
ruin things
the best evil song of all time
is girl you want
and if you slow it down on youtube to 75
which is a fun thing i don't know if you
know you can do this you can slow down
or speed up the speed of a video slow it
down to 75 it becomes a whole new song
and it's real good it's like jazzy funky
version it's good is it like slowing
down jolene
have you never heard oh my god it sounds
it's amazing because suddenly it becomes
like this johnny cash song oh where like
because it's it's not like we're
covering it it's dolly's voice just like
pitch shifted and slow down
and then it's like jolene
jolene
jolene jolie
yeah it's it's like echoey and evocative
and wow you should do that also dolly
parton is maybe the best american
songwriter and one of the best people
period yeah she's done so much for the
world she's amazing there was this
podcast um i will plug another podcast
on this podcast called dolly parton's
america which just sort of investigates
what it means to be american through the
prism of dolly parton and it's
phenomenal it's like eight episodes long
but they have this whole segment about
how the fact that like she wrote jolene
and like i will always love you
in like a day yeah like those two songs
in the same day is astonishing and she
wrote like 3 000 songs over the course
of her career cocaine's a hell of a drug
what could i say
kennedy whiskey
um but yeah like she just seems to be
the most remarkable person yeah um so
yeah i don't know why but it seems like
a relatively decent place to end a
podcast at a comic book what is your
favorite devo song i'm sorry it was
gonna be whip it because i'm so [ __ ]
basic
like i'm the best music videos of all
time i'm an mtv kid and that was my way
into into music videos and that was my
way to diva was if you have a problem
you must
maybe i'll come to rocky okay tonight
and do a song that requires no singing
i'll be back up for you would you yeah
you must wear man y'all must want my
ain't too shy shake that up get straight
move for it move ahead
try to detect it
it's not too late for you dude
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for coming out
to black man beyond guest starring ross
marquan thank you so much
i'm mark bernardin uh we will see you uh
next year
same fat time same black place
smodcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
good night everybody
high fiving a million angels
yeah we're not gonna leave we're just
gonna sit here and make it weird
no you go first that was my experience
um
i think we still have a couple minutes
left i can tell the story i came here
like three or four years ago and edward
james almost was also on the guest list
the loveliest man in the world wow we're
leaving uh we were we were riding on the
little jumper together and so we got
like close and and friendly so we're in
the vancouver airport walking through
and uh eddie who he demands that i call
him eddie and not mr almost
eddie runs into levar burton
and they know each other because
they would right
and so and so they're talking they're
talking whatever and then eddie's like
oh hey mark do you know levar i'm like
no i don't
but i sure would like to
and so uh and so i talked to levar for a
little bit and i tell him he's like what
are you doing i'm a tv writer really
yeah
and then i do the thing that i promised
myself that i would start doing more
which is
there's a person that you that is in
your life that has meant something to
you
tell them how you feel about them
because the chance of you making that
encounter again are slim
and and you should tell people the way
you feel if you can so i'd say lavar i'm
like listen mr burton so call me lavar
so i'm not going to call you the far yet
um i just wanted to tell you that like
you on star trek the next generation
um meant the world to me as a young
black geek who didn't know if there was
a place for him in this space
and so the fact that you were that
character and that you are the man that
you are um helped unlock for me what i
thought the possibility of a future
might be it was like oh man thank you
that's really sweet um
okay see you later
and then we like go our separate ways
except we're in lax still at the [ __ ]
gate
and so then we just need to like walk
together
to the baggage claim
like not acknowledging that i just
poured my heart out to him and then said
goodbye but then didn't actually leave
and so the weird like 10-minute walk
where we're just pretending not to
acknowledge each other
was the most awkward thing i've ever
done and so then i get to baggage claim
and then i get to say
okay bye again
he's like alright yeah peace out and so
i walk uh to the parking garage to get
in my car and he got met by like a dude
because levar doesn't travel alone
there's some giant armenian guy who's
gonna be his bodyguard and pick up his
bags for him and so i get into the
elevator and then suddenly this giant
arm reaches in and stops the elevator
from closing
and then i look out and then levar
sticks his head in
and he's like you can't get rid of kunta
kinte that easy [ __ ]
i was like
i love you forever
thank you so much
that is my levar story about just being
a little awkward when you could leave
but don't yeah so we're just gonna stay
here for another 45 minutes and just
make it [ __ ] weird
do you guys like shrek
nice
same here
you know what's cool what's what
star trek two is a really good movie the
wrath of khan is the best one it really
is by far anyone who disagrees with me i
will fight you to the death
right after this panel which is going to
end tomorrow apparently
but
wrath of khan best star trek movie by
far hands down end of story
if you if you disagree with me i will
fight you to the death
right over there or right back there
probably and then we'll we'll play the
the mock time fight music yes
can i ask you real quick what is your
favorite star trek next generation
episode you can it can be one of the
borg ones it's not one of the boring
ones okay um and it's not gonna be um
yesterday's enterprise which is easy to
do because it's phenomenal inner light
inner light if you're not familiar
um
for the uh i guess for the bonus segment
of this episode
which has had two bonus segments already
it's the episode in which the the
enterprise stumbles across some probe in
deep space
and you know of course the enterprise
scans it because they're just nosey that
way
and uh the the scan activates the probe
which somehow plants something in
picard's mind like the cart's staying in
their bridge what's this and then he
passes out and then we spend the entire
episode in picard's mind where he lives
an entire life
on this planet where like at first he
spends the first couple years trying to
get out then he was resigned like i
guess i'm never going to leave and then
he gets married and has a son and
you know helps like there's some
catastrophe that's happening some solar
whatever the [ __ ] it's an environmental
disaster and he is a scientist is going
to help fix it but then learns that he
can't fix it and so what he's trying to
do is just create some sort of way for
everybody to know that the civilization
existed at all and so he builds
a probe to sends it out with the
totality of this
this culture's sort of emotional history
and their their memories and all that
stuff distilled down into this probe so
that somebody out there in the world
could know they existed
and that's the probe that they found
with the enterprise and so this entire
experience was picard living an entire
life
loving losing people having a son all of
it
that never really existed and so the
episode ends with him waking up and
being like oh that was that was so
[ __ ] weird it's like and you know
health scan everything's fine and i said
can you carry on to yes number one i'm
fine
until he goes back into his quarters and
then you see him pull out this little
like pin penny flute or whatever and
plays this musical theme that he'd been
playing throughout the episode
it's the most beautiful episode of star
trek it is
it's everything that that show could be
it's hope and it's wondering it's
science fiction and it's it's it's it's
amazing and self-contained in one hour
completely you know surprising because a
lot of the best episodes for me were the
ones that took two or three episodes to
wrap up yeah i mean best of both worlds
is phenomenal yeah but you required a
season ending cliffhanger to get there
but between yesterday's enterprise which
also is is terrific it's you know the
perfect alternate history but then in
inner light it's just magnificent yeah
i don't know the name of it but the one
where they somehow get this video game
that it's it's it's like a thing that
goes over their eye and their ear i
think it's the game
is it called what's it called the game
the game okay and it looks like these
you know kind of platelet blood cell
globules are going into like a horn and
then the horn gets all excited and goes
thank you for the deliciousness and then
like
everyone playing this game they're like
having like a uh
like like kind of an
orgasmic reaction to each time they get
in there and they become hooked on it
like a dopamine reaction and i even as a
kid i was seven or when i was watching
whenever i was like this is i think
gonna be important someday i feel like
this is where we're headed and then it's
like think about like instagram and all
that i'm like we are fully living that
that episode is the most prophetic
episode of the entire run of that show
and if you if you get a chance watch the
game
it's on netflix i i would imagine yeah
yeah yeah i remember that was like a
rhiza episode where it starts where like
riker is [ __ ] around on rhizod as he
was wanted to do and like some hot chick
gave him the game and he's like i'm
gonna bring this back to the enterprise
that's right because i'm the worst have
you guys seen the hypercut of riker
sitting down
do you guys know what oh okay okay the
record do it do the right thing this is
the funniest thing and no one unless
someone points it out you don't know it
but every time riker would come into
it's the weirdest thing once you see it
you can't unsee it yeah it's like he had
to make sure that his balls
gently graze the top of every chair
yeah like not like i'm gonna bang them
hard because that's my kink it's just
like let's just make sure that they knew
i was here
[Laughter]
if you get a chance watch the hyper cut
because it's one of the funniest things
you'll ever see there's also a super cut
of patrick stewart doing the the the
shirt tug oh yeah but like every eighth
time the insignia would pop off
and so it was just like think
think and somebody added the doink sound
effect so you just watch all these
bloopers and suddenly just like like
literally sitting in a scene with eight
other people at a conference table it's
like well number one we have a plan
and then the little thing would skitter
across the top of this
the table
oh next generation we do love you so
good stuff
the best the best the very best the
greatest tv show in the history of tv
shows everybody knows that except for
the apprentice
[Music]
all right boys and girls we're gonna go
for real um thank you so much for coming
on playing with us um enjoy the rest of
your con
i'm gonna be back there signing and
selling stuff tomorrow he's going to be
back here signing and selling stuff
tomorrow ming chen is going to be the
host of the rakioki at nine o'clock
um
thanks come on
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sound bob get old i'm kevin smith